Ми знаходимося на території київського
осередку Української академії лідерства.
Це те місце, де ми вперше запустили академію лідерства,
тому часто називаємо це першим осередком.
Територіально ми знаходимося
в Пущі-Водиці, місто Київ.
На цій території ви бачите кілька будівель.
Одна з них є центральною,
тут власне наші студенти мешкають і навчаються,
і так само члени команди мають
свої і помешкання, і офіси.
Тут є зона з харчоблоком, є багато простору,
де влітку ти можеш проводити лекції.
Фактично, це те місце, яке вже випустило чотири когорти
випускників Української академії лідерства,
в той час як інші осередки випустили троє,
чернівецький осередок, який ми лише
в вересні 2018 року запустили, випустив перший раз.
Ми бачили велику кількість молоді на Майдані,
і у мене було відчуття, що ця молодь,
яка має прагнення творити суспільство,
вона не завжди має можливість спілкуватися
про це в школах чи університетах.
Ми хочемо почути молоду людину: які прагнення,
чого хоче, та не просто чого хоче,
а чи має здатність і бажає розвивати здібності
для того, щоб досягати цих цілей.
Ці речи ми перевіряємо на етапі відбору студентів,
коли вони до нас йдуть навчатися.
Цей додатковий рік після школи дає змогу
молодій людині прийняти свідоме рішення –
куди я хочу йти вчитися.
[англійською] Хвилинку, будь ласка.
Будь-ласка, для всієї групи.
Друзі, зараз ми йдемо їсти бутерброди,
чілитися тут в парку і чекати наступних інструкцій
для того, щоб поїхати в Єрусалим.
— А де ми залишаємо речі?
— Ми зараз ідемо туди, бо це перша інструкція.
Там буде нас автобус чекати.
[усі разом вигукують] Женя приїхала!
[на івриті] ♪ Ще Отець наш живий, народ Ізраїля живий! ♪
Ми в експедиції.
Ми переймаємо досвід ізраїльтян,
надихаємося їхніми досягненнями
та переймаємо їхні почуття до своєї країни.
Ми починали навчальний рік перший
з дуже цікавої активності.
Ми в Переяслав-Хмельницькому
організували для наших вже студентів
триденний курс виживання серед природи.
Вони приїхали в Київ з рюкзаками, з валізами,
хтось зі своїм ведмедиком, і так далі, і потім ми їм сказали:
«Народ, ви маєте взяти три найголовніші речі,
які вам потрібні для життя на природі».
Це є дуже гарний спосіб краще пізнати себе.
Абсолютно різні 39 підлітків з усієї країни
приїхавши сюди, у Пущу-Водицю,
все, чого хотіли, це душ і щось перекусити,
і їм було байдуже навіть, де спати.
Ми часто боремося з тим, що молоді люди мають
у собі оцю схильність до консьюмеризму, до споживництва.
Наше завдання показати молодим людям,
яким  ми передаємо естафету лідерства,
що речі, які оточують нас, країна, врешті-решт,
в якій ми живемо, вона не впала звідкись,
а її передали в якомусь конкретному стані,
і треба бути вдячними за це.
♪ Вороги вже недалеко,
гострять шаблі та багнети! ♪
♪ А мені те все байдуже,
бо біля мене справжній друже! ♪
♪ Біля мене друже,
тож мені байдуже, ♪
♪ Хай як доля припече,
поруч другове плече! ♪
Ми з УАЛ Львів.
— Я з Маріуполя.
— А я з Вінниці.
Багато надходить завдань, і я розумію,
що це корисно не тільки для мене –
це корисно для тієї справи, яку я роблю,
для того, навіщо я взагалі живу і
це мене надихає, те, що я не безкорисна.
Це те, що відкриває в тобі щось нове,
і тебе це захоплює.
Академія — це нові знання, це нереальні можливості,
це нереально крутий досвід і це мотивує.
Романе! Зараз, зараз, Романе! Романе, ти готовий?
Творимо себе – творимо Україну!
Кожне завтра розпочинається вже сьогодні!
[радісно вигукують та плескають у долоні]
В академії лідерства викладають кращі викладачі
кращих університетів України.
Така збірна солянка: підприємці,
державні службовці, політичні діячі.
Це не є формальне академічне навчання.
Це є спосіб зацікавити, заангажувати,
навчити молодь критично мислити,
застосовувати матеріал не задля галочки
чи щоб просто автоматично здати ЗНО і далі пройти,
а з усвідомленням того, що ті знання, які ти тут отримаєш,
вони є твоїм інструментарієм подальшого розвитку в житті.
Ми даємо можливість молодим людям зануритися
в контекст того, що відбувається з реформуванням держави,
спілкуватися з людьми, які її реформують
сьогодні своїми руками;
показати їм круті бізнеси, показати їм бізнеси,
які були не успішними, щоб вони розуміли,
що є успішні, і є не успішні історії,
але коли ти реалізуєш неуспішну історію,
ти виходиш з неї сильнішим, щоб почати щось нове
на основі тих висновків, які ти зробив до цього.
Вони волонтерять в госпіталях,
вони волонтерять в школах,
і чим швидше ми надамо можливість молоді
приймати рішення самостійно, але за умов наставництва,
спрямування старших, мудріших,
тим швидше ми будемо розкривати потенціал молоді,
тим менше молоді буде бажати виїхати звідси.
Вони будуть бачити можливості,
які відбуваються в Україні,
і вони прагнутимуть тут творити,
а це вкрай важливо.
Коли ми виходили з монумента,
присвяченому пам'яті загиблим дітям,
нас попросили запам'ятати кожного одне ім'я,
і потім, коли ми вийшли, на виході
попросили пам'ятати це ім'я завжди.
Якщо кожен турист, який відвідає,
пам'ятатиме хоча б одне ім'я,
то ми так зможемо принести пам'ять всіх людей,
які коли-небудь загинули.
Коли мене про це попросили,
я подумала про те,
як багато я не знаю тих людей,
які загинули під час українського Голодомору,
як багато ми не знаємо зараз імен наших героїв,
які помирають зараз за нас,
і як можна на прикладі Ізраїлю
змінювати цю ситуацію у нас.
Що ми даємо в Українській академії лідерства?
З одного боку, ти отримуєш цю впевненість в собі,
ти відкриваєш свій талант, водночас ти робиш
дуже багато речей, які інколи тобі не зручні.
Ти в 6:30 прокидаєшся і біжиш 7-8 кілометрів
і ти бігаєш 6 днів на тиждень.
Ми хочемо, аби вони творили.
Не руйнували, а творили.
І коли в майбутньому вони прийдуть
до місцевого самоврядування,
ввійдуть в різні гілки влади, тому що
вони хотітимуть цього задля того,
щоб змінити життя інших людей,
і ми будемо горді, що ми це зробили.
Ось у нас була одна історія в Одесі.
Одна студентка, її звати Ксенія,
вона вже сьогодні навчається в одному з університетів...
Ми 2 дні вмовляли її батьків.
Ми приїхали в Одесу, зустріч відбулася,
ми пообідали з батьками і з нею.
Розмова тривала десь 2 години.
Ми не змогли переконати батьків,
вона розплакалась,
махнула рукою, вона так
в нашій присутності сказала:
«Та мої батьки "совкові", я думаю інакше, але не можу
піти проти волі своїх батьків, тому дякую, що ви приїхали».
А це була перша одеситка
в Українській академії лідерства,
яку у нас був шанс залучити на навчання
в Українську академію лідерства.
І в результаті, ми вирішили лишитися ще на одну ніч –
щось інтуїтивно стримало нас не поїхати з Одеси.
І буквально наступного ранку
ми отримуємо дзвінок від цієї ж самої дівчинки,
вона каже: «Слухайте, ми всю ніч з батьками говорили,
мої батьки знову хочуть з вами зустрітися».
І ми зустрілися на тому ж самому місці.
Цього разу були сльози, дуже великі сльози, бо батьки сказали:
«Донька нам так розтлумачила свою мотивацію
і бажання вчитись в академії лідерства, і ми зрозуміли,
що ви теж хочете настільки доброго, як і ми для неї».
Я такий: «Так, ми хочемо лише найкращого для неї».
І вони такі: «Ну добре, забирайте її».
Я такий думаю: «Ого, оце так історія».
Ваше завдання ходити по території, запрошувати людей
сюди скуштувати найгірший суп у світі.
Все, все, все, все, друзі,
закінчуємо і більше нічого не вкидаємо.
Є кришка?
— Не мішай поки, не мішай.
— Так, не мішай.
Сьогодні в Ізраїлі Українська академія лідерства
презентує найдивніший вуличний ресторан в історії.
Ми називаємо його «Незлічені»
або «Непораховані з 1932 року».
Ми робимо цю акцію в 30 різних локаціях в Ізраїлі,
для того, щоб продемонструвати важливість проблеми
і для того, аби більше країн змогли визнати
це як геноцид українського народу.
Ми запрошуємо людей на вулиці скоштувати суп,
яким харчувалися українці протягом Голодомору.
Він зроблений з шишок, листя, кори дерев,
і це була найбільш розкішна їжа,
яку могли собі дозволити люди в той час.
Воно гаряче, тому не поспішайте.
Ми живемо в Ізраїлі 3 роки.
Самі ми з Донецька.
Жили в центрі міста там,
до тієї пори, коли росіяни прийшли нас,
як це, [російською] "звільняти", товариство?
Відтоді ми живемо ось тут.
В мене є право на репатріацію.
Це моя донька.
Усі молоді люди круті.
У нас дуже багато талановитої молоді в Україні.
Ти хочеш обрати тих,
хто справді мотивований творити себе
і справді відданий ідеї того,
що він чи вона здатні не тільки творити себе,
але вони здатні вже зараз
змінювати середовище навколо,
зокрема, Україна для них не є пустим словом.
В Українській академії лідерсва
молода людина виходить з розумінням,
а які ж механізми лежать
в основі функціонування суспільства,
в основі функціонування організації,
в основі функціонування чи реалізації проєкту,
як працювати з командами,
як реагувати на якісь стресові ситуації,
як проявляти ініціативу, як залучати ресурси.
Якщо у тебе буде крута команда однодумців,
ти завжди зможеш побудувати продукт,
який привабить увагу найкращих студентів в Україні.
Ці найкращі студенти змотивують до участі в проєкті,
в програмі найкращих викладачів цієї країни,
і разом ми спроможні будемо показати,
що ми заслуговуємо того ресурсу,
який в нас можуть вкладати,
чи то бізнес, чи то держава.
Ми їдемо в Західну Європу, ми їдемо в країни,
які ми називаємо «розвинутими країнами».
І, зокрема, ми їдемо, наприклад,
в Бельгію, в Швейцарію, в Німеччину, Францію,
щоб побачити, що жодна з цих країн
не з'явилась за 10 років –
вона не постала за рік чи за п'ять,
чи навіть два десятки років.
Пішли десятки років, сотні років
для того, щоб ці суспільства сформувалися.
І це десь приземляє нас у відсутності терпіння до того,
що як все так повільно змінюється в Україні.
Потрібно розуміти: щоб в Україні змінювались речі,
треба масштабно змінювати ваш світогляд.
Я вірю, що ми в Україні можемо творити речі,
які будуть корисні і для нас, і для світу навколо.
Наша Україна – це ми.
Все дуже просто.
Визначення, яке допомагає нам відчувати
відповідальність за те, що відбувається тут.
В цьому визначенні також є і філософія того,
що з вдячності тим, наприклад, хто на фронті,
в не найкращих умовах відстоює нас з вами
і право бути тим, ким ми хочемо, право на нашу мрію.
Ми маємо бути тут, для того,
щоб максимально викладатися,
бо ця Україна, про яку ми всі
з вами мріємо, правда ж?
Щоб їй було кого кому творити.